y todas las aprobaciones de seguridad y
eficacia se cumplen nueva york que
empezaría su fase de vacunación contra
el nuevo corona virus el 15 de diciembre
de acuerdo con lo señalado por el
gobernador de este estado estadounidense
en dicho territorio sería aplicado tanto
el antídoto de facer como el de modernas
las autoridades estiman que el primer
envío de facer sería suficiente para
vacunar a 170.000 mallorquinos y que
posteriormente serían recibidas 40.000
dosis del antídoto creado por moderna
los primeros en recibir el fármaco
serían los integrantes de los equipos
médicos y los empleados de las
residencias de ancianos en medio del
anuncio salieron a flote inquietudes
sobre si los indocumentados serían
vacunados una interrogante sobre la cual
todavía no hay claridad y sabemos que no
se puede disuadir a la población
indocumentada a participar
la guía federal hace que los estados
firmen algo llamado acuerdo de
intercambio de datos el gobierno federal
sugiere que identifiquemos a los
destinatarios mediante el número de
seguro social el número de pasaporte
identificación de licencia de conducir
haití number durante los primeros meses
de la pandemia nueva york figuró como el
epicentro del brote en el país y nueve
meses después de la detección de los
primeros casos continúa a la cabeza del
listado de estados afectados por la
emergencia en la unión americana al
sumar más de 34.000 de las muertes
reportadas hasta la fecha este miércoles
el número de pacientes hospitalizados
por ccoo el 19 en todo el territorio
estadounidense superó los 100.000 lo que
equivale a casi el doble de la cifra
registrada en la primera ola